>> Laura: A PROMISE TAYLOR
RESPONSE TONIGHT TO WHAT WE HAVE
BEEN DISCUSSING THROUGHOUT THE
SHOW, THE LEFT KILLING FREE
SPEECH AND SILENCING VOICES,
INTIMIDATION AND TIME TIMES
SLANDER.
OUR FOUNDERS WARNED ABOUT THE
DANGERS OF LIMITING SPEECH.
BEN FRANKLIN WROTE, "WHOEVER
WOULD OVERTHROW THE LIBERTY OF A
NATION MUST BEGIN BY SUBDUING
THE FREENESS OF SPEECH.
AND YET, HERE WE ARE.
AS WE HAVE SEEN THROUGHOUT THE
SHOW, WHEN INDIVIDUALS SAY
THINGS THAT ARE UNCOMFORTABLE
FOR THE SECULAR LEFT, THEY
AREN'T CHALLENGED OR DEBATED.
THEY ARE BRANDED, DEMONIZED, AND
SOMETIMES EVICTED ALTOGETHER
FROM THE PUBLIC SQUARE.
THAT IS NOT THE AMERICAN WAY.
WE ARE WINNING THE WAR OF IDEAS
ON IMMIGRATION, THE ECONOMY,
LIFE, TRADE, AND YES, POLITICAL
CORRECTNESS, WHICH IS WHY WE ARE
SEEING THE LEFT-WING RETALIATORY
HIT SQUAD POPPING UP EVERYWHERE.
TODAY IN ACADEMIA, AND
HOLLYWOOD, AND IN THE MEDIA, THE
LEFT WILL BROOK NO DISSENT, AND
THEY WILL MILITANTLY POLICE THE
BORDERS OF THEIR STALE ORTHODOXY
BORDERS OF THEIR STALE ORTHODOX
ORTHODOXY.
WELL, WE ARE NOT GOING TO STAND
FOR THIS.
SO TONIGHT, I AM ANNOUNCING A
NEW RECURRING SERIES ON
"THE INGRAHAM ANGLE."
IT'S CALLED "DEFENDING THE
FIRST," WHERE WE WILL EXPOSE THE
ENEMIES OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT,
OF FREE EXPRESSION, AND EVERY
THOUGHT, WHILE SHOWCASING THOSE
BRAVE VOICES MAKING A DIFFERENC.
IF YOU HAVE BEEN SUBJECTED TO
THREATS OR INTIMIDATION BECAUSE
OF YOUR SPEECH, I WANT TO KNOW
ABOUT IT.
TWEET ME BECAUSE WITHOUT FREE
SPEECH AND A FREE CONSCIENCE, WE
ARE NOT TRULY A FREE PEOPLE.
WE ARE NOT AFRAID TO DEBATE